- Depuis l'enlèvement, samedi
dernier, de 17 missionnaires,
parmi eux, 1 Canadien
et 5 enfants, les ravisseurs
multiplient les démonstrations
de force, réaffirmant,
sur les réseaux sociaux,
leur intention d'exécuter
les otages si la rançon de
17 millions $ n'est pas payée.
ROZY AUGUSTE DUCÉNA, Réseau
national, défense droits humains
- Est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
par rapport aux menaces?
Nous pensons que oui. Pourquoi?
Parce qu'il y a plusieurs
personnes, plusieurs Haïtiens et
Haïtiennes qui ont été enlevés,
qui ont été assassinés
même après le versement
de la rançon exigée.
- Des menaces qu'Ottawa
prend très au sérieux.
Affaires mondiales Canada nous
informent que l'otage canadien
est un homme originaire
de l'Ontario et que les agents
consulaires sont en contact avec
sa famille. À la Maison-Blanche,
on souhaite mettre un frein
à la prolifération des gangs
criminels en Haïti.
"Nous voulons renforcer
la capacité de la police
haïtienne de lutter contre
les gangs armés." La secrétaire
de presse adjointe admet que
c'est un travail difficile et
de longue haleine, un travail
d'autant plus ardu qu'hier,
le directeur général
de la police a démissionné.
- Les membres du gang armé qui
les ont enlevés contrôlent toute
la commune où ils sont en train
d'opérer, ce qui veut dire qu'en
fait, il y a des possibilités
pour que ces missionnaires
ne soient pas gardés
en un seul endroit.
- Le groupe criminel 400 Mawozo
contrôle près de la moitié
de la région métropolitaine
de Port-au-Prince, un territoire
de plus de 1900 kilomètres
carrés, un groupe armé
jusqu'aux dents et qui sème
la terreur en toute impunité.
- La majorité des armes à feu
qui circulent sur le territoire
haïtien proviennent
des États-Unis d'Amérique.
- Face à l'horreur,
les familles des otages
ont adressé une lettre
aux ravisseurs.
Une lettre qui décrit
leur impuissance, leur tristesse
et dans laquelle ils disent
prier pour les otages
ainsi que leurs ravisseurs.
En Haïti, l'insécurité rampante
attise la colère de la rue.
"Il n'y a pas d'essence
et nos enfants ont faim."
"Les autorités nous prennent
en otage", dit cet autre
Haïtien. "Il n'y a pas
d'essence depuis trois jours."
(coup de klaxon)
Les accusations de corruption
portées contre de hauts
fonctionnaires, l'inflation
et l'insécurité plongent,
encore une fois, Haïti
dans une spirale de violence.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa